Do my rife programs from May 2020 when I had active recurrence of my ovarian cancer
cover be currently when I don't have any cancer according to the ecologist remember just
because you have no evidence of disease according to the neurologist who still want to be ready
your cancer programs. But really have inflamed gut since December and suffering from extreme
large. So if you don't know what large is that's what's called it's low anterior resection syndrome
and that is you can end up with the increased frequency of bowel movements, increased urgency,
all sorts of different things like that. And you so but no your rife programs are not
you're not and your current rife programs are for your ovarian cancer they're not for
any bowel issues any gut issues per se. So this is where you may go hey can I get a new rife program
for my current symptoms my current disorder my current whatever I have going on this is where
you may want to ask for that. So back to the home page of your of the you know the membership home page
you're looking at on that home page you're looking down and see I'm going to get a cheek swab and I'm
going to you know get asked for rife programs. So that's what you would do. So I would suggest
you we I would still put in the ovarian cancer programs because I still think you need to be ready
that even if you have no evidence of disease. But certainly we can put in other frequencies for
other things or I could actually have probably just create another little folder for you
for helping you with whatever else you got to point on and that's why you use that form and let me know.